So last time we finished up
by playing the game of Nim,
I never remember,
I hope that the game of men was a game
where I would those two piles of stones
are we,
we may do with lions on the board and
the winner was the person who who picked
up the last stone,
I'm gonna be Agile,
you have to pick piles and I want to use
the game of naming to make a transition
here.
So we'd pointed out about the game of Nim
was it illustrated very nicely for us.
That's a games can have first mover
advantages or they can have second mover
advantages,
a very small change in the game.
Essentially a suppose small change in it.
And where we started from could switch
a game from a game with a first mover
advantage to a game with a second
mover advantage. All right,
now today I want to make it just draw
a slightly grander lesson out of that
game. So not only was it the case that
that's the game sometimes has first mover
advantages and sometimes
has second mover advantages.
But moreover we could tell when it had a
first mover advantage and we could tell
when he had a second mover advantage.
It's not right.
When we actually looked at the
initial setup of those stones,
we knew immediately that's a game
in which player one is going to win.
Or alternatively we knew immediately
that's a game which player two is going to
win.
All right?
Now it turns out that that idea is very
general and actually has a name attached
to it.
And that name is de Mello.
So today we'll start off by talking
about a theorem due to a guy called zoom
mellow and the idea of this therapist.
Next,
we're gonna look at games
more general than just Nim.
And we're going to ask the question,
uh,
under what circumstances would you know
about a game? I either the player one,
the person who goes first can force a
whim or the player to can force a win or
what allow a third possibility, which
is it's going to be a tie. All right,
so here's the theorem. Suppose
there are two players in this game,
like the game we looked at last time,
and suppose I won't to
find this formally now,
but suppose the game is a
game of imperfect, infamous,
or have perfect information.
So we're only my perfect information.
I'll define that later on the class.
But for now,
all I mean is that whenever play,
whenever it player has his turn to move,
that player knows exactly
what has happened prior in
the game. So for example,
all these sequential move gains,
we've been looking at our moves of
perfect information. When I get to move,
I know exactly what you did yesterday.
I know what I did the day before
yesterday. I was so, all right,
so it's a game of perfect information.
I'm going to assume that the game
has a finite number of nodes.
So two things here. It can't
go on forever. This game,
and also there's no point
at which it branches in an
infinite way. All, all right?
There's a finite number of nodes and
we'll assume that the game has three
possible outcomes. And actually there's
a more general version of this therapy,
but this will do for now.
The three possible outcomes are
either a win for player one,
so I'll call it w sub one
or a loss for player one,
which is obviously a win for player too,
or tie.
All right? So the game like name
last time literally had two outcomes.
So here we're going to go up for three
outcomes or a three Oh three or fewer
outcomes I should say. All right,
so these are the conditions
and here's the results.
So I said three it could be three
but it could also be to here.
I'm just allowing for three.
One is true. All right?
So under these conditions,
the following is true.
Either play a one
can force or win.
So either it's the case that this game
is a game that had player one plays as
well as they can. They're going
to win the game. All right.
No matter what player
two Dash Oh two oh sorry.
Oh one
can at least to tie.
Yeah.
All right.
Which means player one complaints such
a way that they can assure themselves of
a tie regardless of what player too does.
Oh,
it could be a game in which to
can force a loss on one.
All right, so when is this? All right.
All right,
so this third, when you first look at
it, it doesn't seem to save very much.
I you're staring at this thing.
You might think that we already knew that
we're looking at games that only have
three possible outcomes, win, loss or tie.
All right,
so it doesn't seem so surprising.
If you look at this third minute says,
why are they going to end up
with a win or a loss or Tai Chi?
But that's not quite what the Theorem
says, right? The therm say is not,
and you're going to end up there.
We knew that already,
but but games divided themselves get
into these foam divide themselves into
those games in which player
one has a way of winning,
regardless of what player too does,
right?
Or Games which pay one has
a way of forcing a Thai
regardless of what player one
does. By two days or play
a two as a way of winning,
regardless of what our player one does.
Ratchet, these games all have a solution.
It's just go back to Nim to illustrate
the point. All right, so in Nim, uh,
actually there's no ties.
We can forget the middle of the years
and in Nim under certain circumstances,
it is the case that player
one can force a win.
Who remembers what the case was for
when player one can force a win?
Anybody when people who played last time,
Oh
yes, I know some. Somebody
here just, yeah, sure.
I just shout it out
of,
all right, so if the, if the
piles starts on the call,
if the pile start on equal,
then player one can actually force a win.
So in Nim
in them, if the piles are
on equal, not the stars,
then one can force a win.
It really doesn't matter what
two does to his toast. All right.
Or the alternative case is the
piles are equal at the stars.
And if that equal at the start,
then it's play a one who's toast,
right player to is kind of oh
well the force, the loss on one.
So to can force.
I lost on one [inaudible].
All right everyone remember
that from last time? Yeah,
it just before the weekend and be so
far. Let me go. All right, so, so this,
this theorem applies to
all games of this form.
So what games are this fullness
and think of some other examples.
So one example is tic TAC toe. All right?
Everyone knows the rules of ticked out.
I didn't even know we call
it noughts and crosses,
but you guys call it a tic TAC toe.
Is that right?
Everyone know what Tic Tac toe is?
Yeah. So in Tic Tac toe, oh, which,
which category is Tic Tac toe?
Is it the game?
Which player one can force a win or is
it the category in which player one can
only force a tie or is it a category?
What you'd rather go second
and play two could force it.
Force of wind for buy a two or lost
replay one, which just tic TAC toe.
That's a show of hands here.
Who Thinks Tic Tac toe is a game
which play one can force a win.
Who Thinks Tic Tac? That is a game which
would play, won't get any force a tie.
And I think it's probably one who
thinks a player is going to win.
I think you'll read most of you're right.
It's a game.
It's a game in which if
people play correctly then
it will turn out to be a tie.
All Right,
so tic TAC toe
TGC TIC TAC toe is a
game that leads to a tie.
All right? Play a one can still make a
mistake, in which case they can lose,
play a tube and make a mistake,
in which case there would lose.
But there is a way of playing
that forces a tie. All right,
so these are fairly simple games.
Let's talk about more complicated games.
So what about the game of checkers?
Right?
So the game of checkers meets these
conditions. It's a two player game.
You always know all the moves prior to
your move. It's fine. I, it's all right.
There's some rules and checkers that
prevented going on forever and there are
two or three outcomes.
I guess there's a third outcome.
If you've got into a cycle,
you could tie, all right,
it's a checkers is a fits all these
disruptions and what this theorem tells us
is that checkers has a solution,
right?
I'm not trying to know what that solution
is or I think actually somebody did
computer it quite recently,
even though the last few months,
I just forgot to Google it
this morning to remind myself,
but what the storm shelters, even
before this, people have computed it.
Check has has a solution. All right,
let's be a bit more ambitious.
What about chess? Chess meets
this description, right?
Chest is a two player game.
Everybody knows all the moves before them.
It's sequential. All right?
It has finite number of moves.
It's a very large number,
but it is finite. All right,
and it has three possible
outcomes, a win, a loss or a tie.
That's been to be careful. The reason
it's finite is that if you cycle,
I forget what it is, three
times, then they get them.
The game is declared a drawer at a
time. All right, so what's this there?
I'm telling us,
it's telling us that there
is a way to soul chess.
Tell just the is a way to solve
test chest has a solution, right?
We don't know what that solution is.
It could be that solution is that
player one. Who's the Pi with the white.
The white pieces can force awareness.
It could be that probably one can only
force a tie and it could even be that
player Tuk and forced to win. All
right? We don't know what it is,
but there is a solution. All
right? There's a catch to this.
There are much the catch.
The catch is it doesn't actually tell us.
This term is not going to
tell us what that solution is.
It doesn't tell us how to
play this through in it of
itself doesn't tell us how
to play chess.
It just says there is a way to play chess.
Alright.
Alright,
so we're going to try and prove this.
We don't often do proofs in class,
but the reason I would approve this
particular one is because the proof is
instructive as part of it,
of the Qr at Yale. All right?
So here's another example here and some
other examples you could think of chess
as being the most dramatic example.
All right?
All right.
So the reason I want to actually spend
some time proving this today is because
we're going to prove it by induction.
We're gonna prove it. My induction. All
right, I'm going to sketch the program,
not gonna go through every possible step,
but I want it.
I want to give people here a feeling for
what a proof by induction looks like.
And the reason for that is my guest is,
but it's find out how many of you
seen a proof by induction before?
How many have nots? Right?
So for those who haven't,
I think it's a good thing in life at
one point in your life to see a proof by
induction.
And for those who have,
my guess is you source and I'm awful
math class in, uh, in high school.
And it gets when, you know, it didn't
take over your hay, but it kind of,
the excitement of it doesn't catch on.
I'm hoping to make this is a context
where it might appeal. All right,
so proof by induction,
we're going to prove this by induction on
the maximum
length
of the game. Well, cool.
That n n the maximum. Next look,
it's what do we mean by this?
If I write down a tree,
I can always look at all the pause
from the beginning of the tree,
all the way through to the end of the
trash that your wife and beginning of the
tree all the way through
to the end of the tree.
And I'm gonna look at the path in that,
in that particular tree that has
the largest length. All right?
And I'll call that the length of the game,
the maximum length of the game.
All right? So we're gonna do induction
on the maximum length of the game.
All right? So how do we start a proof by
induction? It's just remind us to house.
There's people who've seen the before.
We're going to prove
that this therom is true.
The claim and the Theorem is true for
the easy case when the game is only one
move long.
All right?
That's the first step and then we're going
to try and show that if it's true for
all games of length,
less than or equal to n whatever n is,
then it must therefore be true
for games of length and plus one.
All right? That's the two. That's the way
you do a proof by induction. All right,
so let's just see how that works
in practice. All Ryan says,
start with the easy step and we'll do
it in some detail more detail than you
really need to in a math class.
So if any equals one,
what are these games look
like? Well, let's look at
some examples here. So here's,
I came, it's pretty triggered of KF and
is equal to one, but let's do it anyway.
All right,
so the game might look like this.
Play a one is going to move his player
one moving the games or your length
wanting to play. One is the only
player who ever gets to move.
So the game might look like,
like this,
I'm not put in a fifth branch
might look like this. All right?
And at the end of this game,
rather than putting payoffs,
let me just put the outcome.
So the outcome must either
be a win or a tie or a loss.
So I suppose it looks like this.
Suppose it's a win or here we could have
a tie or here we can have a win again
or here we can have a loss
and here we could have a tie.
All right, so in this particular gay
man, in this particular game, uh,
I claim it's pretty clear
this game has a solution.
It's pretty clear what one should
do. All right. What should one do?
One should pick one of her choices
that leads to a win to be careful.
I'll put one in here just
to distinguish who it is.
He's actually winning and losing.
All right, so in this, in this game,
I claiming that this game has a pretty
obvious solution. Either play a one,
it's going to choose this brunch that
leads to a win or this Bronx that leads to
awareness. And either way play a one
is going to win, right? The obvious,
it's all this. It's kind of painful.
All right, so I claimed this game,
we can actually replace this first
node with what's going to happen,
which is probably the one one's going
to win. Is that right? That was easy.
That's a good enough to example.
We'll do three. All right,
so here's a another possible example,
and this is again play a one is
gonna move here at this time,
the possible outcomes or
a tie or a loss or a loss.
All right? Once again,
it's a one player game.
This time he has three choices and the
three choices need to a tie or he loses.
So I claim on together this system,
Paul,
what player one should do is what choose.
The tie isn't,
it says no way of winning,
but in that case you can actually force
it and you can actually choose the tie,
in which case he's going to die.
So this game has a solution
called choose the tie. And again,
we could replace the first note of the
game with what's actually gonna Happen,
which is a tie. Everyone happy?
Alright, there's one other possibility.
I guess the other possibility is
that if I want has a lot of choices,
maybe, maybe four choices in
this case. Once again, play
a one, he's going to move.
But in each case, unfortunately
for player one, in each case
the outcome is the player one loses.
All right?
So this is a game in which player one
is going to lose no matter what they do.
Once again,
it has a solution.
The solution is player one is
toast and he's going to lose.
All right,
so I claim this is where he captured
all the possibilities of games of length
one. All right. I mean you can bet,
you could imagine that they
could be more branches on them,
but basically they're doing these
three possibilities. Either.
It's the case that one of
those branches leads to a win,
in which case the solution
is player one wins.
Or it's the case that that none
of the branches have wind in them,
but one of them has a tie, in which case
probably one was going to time orange.
The case that all the
branches have lost in them,
in which case player one's going to lose.
All right,
so I claim I'm done for games
of length one everyone. Okay,
does that SAP is deceptively easy,
but there it is.
All right. Now we do the inductive
step, the big step. All right.
We're going to do is we're going to
assume that the statement of the Theorem,
which I've now hidden, unfortunately
that, I mean that'd be on the height.
I can,
let me easy.
All right.
It's now visible.
Good.
So now let's assume that the statement
of this theorem is true for all games
length less than,
less than or equal to add.
All right.
I suppose that's the case.
Suppose
the claim is true
for all games of this type of length,
less than or equal to some end.
All right,
well we need to show is we're going to
try and show is therefore it will be true
for all games of length. N
Plus One. What we want to
show is
we claim
therefore therefore
it will be true
for games of length
n plus one.
Wow, that's a key step in
inductive proofs. All right,
so how are we going to do that? Well,
let's have a look at a game of length.
N Plus One. All right? Now obviously
I can't use thousands. He has, let me,
let me choose some relatively small
numbers, but the idea we'll go through.
So let's have a look at a game.
All right,
so here's a game in which
play a one moose first
player to move second.
That's supposed if player too does this,
then one only has little
choice here, uh, up here.
Then one has a more complicated
choice perhaps to could move again.
One, two. Okay. All right,
so this is quite a complicated
little game up here and down here.
Just make a little bit
less complicated here.
The game looks like this, and then
comes to an end right to the tree.
Looks like this. I haven't put the
end, I haven't with the outcomes on it,
but the tree looks like this. All right,
so how long is this tree? First of all,
while I claim that the longest path in
this tree from the beginning to the end
has four steps. It's just
check. All right, so one,
two, three, fourth. I came as
the longest, the longest path,
and the path going down this way only
has three moves in it. All right,
so this is a game of length
four. All right. All right.
This is the game of length for so,
so we can apply it to our claim.
Let's assume that the theorem holes
for all trees length three or fewer.
So that n plus one is four for the purpose
of our example. All right? All right,
so here's in this example,
in this example,
I don't know if it hit
after hit and this example
and equals three.
So the n plus one equals four.
All right, I'm going to have a happy
with this and this and the example.
All right,
now what I want to observe about this is
the following contained in this n plus
one or the game of length
four awesome smaller games.
You could think of them as sub games,
the games within the game. Is that right?
So let's have a look
I claim in particular,
let's draw around them in pink.
There's a game here
that follows player one choosing
up and there's a game here
that follows play one choosing down.
Is that right?
All right, and I guess, okay, so
these are both games. All right,
and what do we have here?
So this little game and here,
the game and the top circle the game
that follows player one moving up,
that's a game and it has a length. All
right, so this is the thing is a game.
Okay,
this is a game and I'm going to
call it a sub game. Some jargon we,
well we're getting used to,
they throw them this semester.
It's a game within the game. It's based
off. Again, this is a sub game and
okay,
this is a sub game following
one choosing
op pets put up in here.
Following up,
I claim that this game has a length.
This sub game has a link.
So we knew that we started from a game
of length four we've taken one of the
moves and it's meant Mesh.
Make sure this is actually a
game of length three right?
It's the game started here.
It's a big game of length three
because you could go one, two,
three moves that right? So this is
a game of length three. Alright,
so this is a sum game
following one choosing up and
it's the sub game has length
three.
All right and down here,
down here,
this is also a sub game.
It's a game that follows
play a wireman choosing down
following,
one choosing
down.
And this little sub game
has
Lincoln high.
We have to be a little bit careful.
You might think that since we started
from a game of length for after the first
move,
we must be in a move of games of length
three but actually that's not true.
And if we don't carefully,
we'll notice that this game down here,
that game starting here, uh, actually, uh,
isn't a blank three it's
of length to that, right?
So even though we started from a game
of length four by going this way,
we put ourselves into a game of length
two. Is that right? Right. So one,
two or one two. What up?
All right. But it has length
two.
Okay.
All right.
So in this example and his three
and n plus one is four and our,
our assumption, our induction
assumption is what we've assumed
that the claim of the theorem holes for
all games less than or equal to n which
in this case means less than
or equal to three. All right.
So what does that tell? That tells
us, it tells us by our assumption,
by our assumption,
this game,
which I've put a pink circle around on
the top, this is the game of length three.
This game has a solution, right? It must
have a solution because it's the length,
it's a length three or less.
All right?
So by
the induction hypothesis as
it's called by the induction,
okay.
Hypothesis. This is a technical term,
but what's the induction hypothesis?
Niche thing?
Why?
The assumption that we made
this game has a solution.
This game has a solution,
right? It's a game of length. Three.
Three is less than or equal to.
And in this case,
so this guy must have a solution.
Now I didn't immediately know
by starting at it what it is,
but let's suppose it was w
yeah, say it was probably all right.
And the game down below.
This is also a game and it's a game of
length two but two is less than three as
well too. Is that something equal to
three? So this game also has a solution.
Okay.
This game also by the same assumption,
I had the same assumption has a solution.
So it's solution is say, I
don't know, maybe it's out.
All right, so what does that mean to
say that these games have solutions?
In this case we're going to assume
W is this one and is this word.
What does it mean? It means that we could
just, as we did with the games up there,
we could put the solution at
the beginning of the game.
We know that if we get into this game,
we're going to get the solution of this
game and we know if we get into this
game, we're going to get the
solution of this game. All right?
So we can replace this
one with its solution,
which by assumption was w
and this one by it solution,
which by assumption was owl.
And here I want to be really careful.
I need to keep track
of which person it is.
It's a win or a loss for this was a win
for player one and it was a loss for
player too, and this was a loss for
player one and it was a win for biopsy.
All right? All right, so these games,
each of them have some
solution and this case,
I've written down the
solutions as w o l all right,
so now what can we do?
Let me just bring down this board again.
I can translate this game
into a very simple game.
That's all I'm going to translate up here.
So this game can be translated,
just follows,
play a one moves.
If he goes up then he hits
a w
and if he goes down,
he hits a loss.
All right?
So in this particular example,
player one is effectively choosing
between going up and finding himself in a
game which has a solution
and the solution is he wins.
It's all going down and finding himself
in a game which has a solution and the
solution is he's toast.
All right? But that's what,
that's a one move game.
That's a one move game.
So we knew this is the
solution in particular. He's
going to choose up, right?
This one has a solution. All right, this
hi.
Hey solution.
It is a game off the length one.
So what do we do?
All right.
It's almost schematically we took a game
of length n plus one in this case that
was four and we pointed out that once
play or one that has made her first move.
In this game we are in a game
or in a sub game if you like,
that has length less than four. It
could be three, it could be to whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
Stop getting more in by assumption
that game has a solution.
So it's really effectively pay a one is
choosing between going into a game with
solution win or going into
a game with Ellucian loss.
And if there were 50
another sub games here,
each one would have a
solution in each one play.
One will able about associate that
solution with what he's going to get,
what she's going to get.
All right,
so I claim that if it in fact is true
that each of these sub games of a length,
three or less how to solution,
then the game of length four must
have a solution, which is what?
It's the solution which is play a
one should pick the best sub game.
Alright.
People convinced by that step.
People are looking slightly,
um, during the headlamps now.
So I'm going to say it
again. All right. All right.
We started by assuming that all games
have length three or last one and or less
have a solution.
We pointed out that any game that has
length n plus one can we thought of as an
initial move by player one followed by
a game of length and or less and a few I
should say.
All right.
Each of those games of an or
fewer steps has the solution.
So player one is just going to choose
the game that has the best solution for
her and we're done. All right.
In this particular example,
play I won is going to choose up
and therefore the solution to
this parent game, it's polite,
it's player one witness.
All right?
Now the hard step,
I think it improves by induction
is realizing that you're dumb.
So I claim when now dumb.
Why are we done?
While we know that was pretty easy that
all games of length one have a solution
that was pretty trivial and we've shown
that if any game of length n or fewer
has a solution, then games of
end pass one have a solution.
So now to see how we could proceed.
We know that games of length
one to have a solution.
So let's consider games of length to
write games of length to uh, two
games. The like to have a solution.
While that set any quarter one,
we know that we know that if games or
ninth one to have a solution that any game
of length two could be thought of as
an initial step followed by a game of
length one but then as a solution.
So therefore games with
links to have a solution,
but I don't think of it that games
have length three. All right.
We've shown the games with length one of
a solution and games were links to have
a solution, right? And he gave
him a blank. Three can be,
can be thought of as a game in which
there's an initial step followed by iser
game of length one or a game of links
to each of which have a solution.
So once again, play a game, a game of
length three has a solution and so on.
All right,
so games deduction,
they work by building up on the length
of the game and we'll run the APP knowing
that we're done.
All right.
For those people who've never seen
a proof by induction, don't worry,
I'm not going to test you on a proven
induction on the, uh, on the, uh, uh,
um,
on the exam.
I just wanted you to see one once and
it'll take a deep breath and try and
digest this a little bit by
playing a game. All right,
so I'll leave it up there.
I'll leave it up there
as you can stare at it.
Yeah,
I want it down and get it later,
right.
I,
let's try and actually play a game and
see if we can actually throw any light on
this.
Yeah.
All right. So when I'm going to pick
out volunteers like I did last time,
but first of all, let me tell you what
the game is. So once again, I'm going to,
I'm going to have rocks in
this game and once again,
I'm going to approximate this rocks
with marks on the blackboard. All right?
So here's an example.
Okay.
And the example is this,
the game involves an array of rocks.
So here the array has one,
two, three, four, five rows,
and three columns.
So the rocks and all range
as they were before in piles,
but rather in a sort of pretty
array, right? She made it more even.
But this is one, two, three, four,
five rows and one, two, three columns.
That's in this example. All
right, but in general, in general,
there's an array of rocks
and times n
alright.
And
we're going to play sequentially with the
players. And the way that, the way they,
the game is gonna work is this
is meant to be in this row.
The way the world's going,
the way the game is going to work
is when it's your turn to move,
you have to point to one of these rocks
and whichever rock you points too,
I will remove.
I will delete that rock and all the rocks
that lie above or to the right of it
all rocks that to the northeast of it.
So for example,
if you pointed to this rock,
right,
then I will remove this rock.
And also this one, this one,
and this one.
Right.
And if the next person comes
along and chooses this one,
then I will remove this one and also
that one. Okay. I'm gonna understand.
All right.
And the game
is,
the game is lost because we care.
This is important.
The game is lost by the person
who ends up taking the last rock.
The loser is the person who
ends up removing the last rock.
All right.
Perhaps some volunteers.
Can I volunteer people?
One.
How about the guy with the white tee
shirt with the yellow on there? All right.
Okay. Come on up front. All right. And uh,
who else can I volunteer?
Everyone's looking away from me. Uh,
desperate looking away from me. Uh, okay.
How about the guy with the Yale
sweatshirt on the Yale Law? Yeah,
the l football sweatshirt on.
Okay. All right, so come on up.
Your name is, I just get them. Let
me get a mic up here. Thank you.
Great.
Your name is Noah Noah,
and your name is to the when
it Koran. Koran. Okay. So no,
and Kronner our players. All right.
Everyone understand the rules.
You understand the rules.
Good? Yup. All right,
so what do we make that
Noah go first and Noah,
which rock are you going to
removed from the last rock?
Loses that one. That one.
Okay, so no, it chose this one.
So I'm going to move this
one on the one above it.
All the rocks and and east or deleted all
the rocks to the north and east of it.
I believed it or wait, wait, that. That,
that means you lost rock losers.
Okay, last one. Ah, okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay, good. All right, so all right.
That one, that one. Okay,
so now we have an l shape.
Okay.
No, that one. All right.
That one. That one. Okay. Okay.
Okay. All right, so, so we're
done. All right. All right.
Okay. Everyone understand
how that works. All right.
Round of applause for our players,
please. All right, thank you.
Let me get to more volunteers
now. Everyone's seen it. These,
these guys had the hard job that to
figure it out. Cold. Two more volunteers.
Oh, I'd have to volunteer. I mean, there's
somebody volunteering, volunteering.
Great. I have one volunteer. You
can pick an opponent to do bike.
Okay,
there you go. Okay. Thank
you. Uh, your name, what is
this? Wait for the mixer here.
So your name is Peter. Peter, and
your name is Justin. All right.
All right. Let me put
some, a new array up here.
All right, so let's put a newer array
up here and it's telling us, make it,
it doesn't have to be all,
it doesn't make it this time it a
bit more complicated. So I'll have
five,
that's a four rows and five columns this
time. All right, so this time, okay,
so last time I, last time I had five
rows and three columns, and this,
I'm going to have four rows
and five columns, four rows,
and five columns. All
right? Uh, away you go.
Move out the way.
What did you stand a bit nearer the board?
Make it a little easier for people to
see what's going on. They go. All right.
So Peter, you want to go first? Sure,
that one. Okay, so this one goes,
which means, which means, uh,
all of the ego as well.
All right.
Then we're going to advice from the
floor and we just shout things out.
Not too loud. I try. Go on here.
Okay.
Well we're back to our l shape again.
Yeah.
Ah,
all right. Now if you look can see what's
going on. All right. All right. Oh,
go here and speed it. All right. All
right. All right. Thank you. All right,
so round of applause again.
All right.
Thank you guys.
So here's what I claim about this game
first. And this is the formal pain.
This is a lot harder than the
game we played last time, right?
Everyone convinced by that. All right,
so here's going to be a, an exercise. Uh,
I'll sell it as a challenge.
I may even put it formally on the
problem set this week, but if, if,
if that's what just say, if I do put
this on the problem set this week,
I don't expect you all to solve it.
All right?
If I do put it on the promise that
it's an optional problem, right?
But here's the challenge.
The challenge is
I claim, Oh, I know from
Somalia who's Theorem that no,
most of what an is and
no matter what em is,
this game has a solution,
right?
Yeah.
So there's a mother's theorem tells us
this game highs,
a solution.
I notice it could have a different
solution depending on the end and the amp
depending on how many rows and
how many columns is that right?
So depending on an and a,
each [inaudible] has a solution,
is that right? Is that
right? Right, right.
So which could depend
good. Depends on the m and m on
the number of rows and columns.
Just as a Nim. It depended on how
there's piles started out. All right,
so what's going to be the homework
assignments? Find the solution,
find the solution.
Homework.
What is
this?
All right, so I claim,
let me give you a hint.
I claim it is useful to remember
that there is a solution.
All right.
It turns out to be useful to remember
that that wasn't much of a hint.
You knew that already, but then
I just emphasize that. Okay.
Okay.
So I want to do a bit of a transition now.
Where are you from these games like chess
and checkers and like this game with
the rocks or Nim and I want to be a
little bit formal for a while. All right,
so why don't we haven't done for a while.
Actually we listened to the midterm
is write down some formal definitions.
So I'm going to do that now.
Yeah.
Oh,
at least one of these boards back.
All
right.
So as I warned right,
very early on the class,
there were some points of the day when
we have to stop and do some work and the
next 20 minutes or so is such a point.
All
right.
So, okay, what is this? This is formal
stuff
and the first thing I want to do is I
want to give you a formal definition of
something I've already mentioned today
and that's the idea of perfect and for
the inflammation. So what we've been
looking at, or listening to the mid term,
our games have perfect information.
So at gay men
all have perfect information.
Game of perfect information
is one
in which
at every node or each node,
each node in the game,
the player
who's turn
it is to move with that note.
All right, who's turn it is to move? No,
it was which node
she is at.
Okay.
All right.
It's just a very simple idea.
Like every game we've seen since
the mid term, how's this property?
When you're playing this game, you knew
where you are. You know where you are,
so you know which node your
ass. You know what, what's uh,
you know what your choices are
and what that means implicitly is
she must know how she got there.
All right? So the whole history of the
game is observed by everybody. I'm, I'm,
when I get to move,
I know what you did yesterday.
I know what I did the day before yesterday
from playing with a third person that
I know what they did the day before
that. All right? So very simple idea,
but it's turns out to be an idea that's
actually allows us to a very simple idea.
Did you use for things like backward
induction? Very simply. All right. Now,
so far all we've been doing
is thinking about such games.
The games like perfect competition
kicks for games like a competition,
contrary competition between firms or
games like the games where we were setting
up incentives or games like Nim and
we've have been solving these games by
backward induction rather informally.
All right.
What I want to add in now is the notion
of a strategy in these games, right?
When we had, when we had to
simultaneous move games strategies,
we're really unproblematic obvious what
strategies were, but when we have games,
there's sequential that go on over over
a period of time and inflammation is
emerging over a period of time.
We need to be little careful what
we mean by a strategy. All right,
so what I wouldn't want to do is I want
to define a pure strategy at least as
follows,
so a pure strategy,
a pure strategy
that's apply.
Hi,
in a game of perfect information.
Okay.
Some of the Games we've
been talking about games,
if you can represent by trees is what?
It's a complete,
it's a complete,
it's a complete plan.
It's a complete plan
of action.
In other words,
what it does is it specifies
which action
I should take.
Okay.
Should take her, cause that's what make
it should say gonna say we'll sake.
We'll take at each
of eyes nodes each of i's decision nodes
21st read this definition.
It seems completely uninteresting and
unproblematic a pure strategy for player.
I just tells you in this game,
whenever you might be called upon to move,
it tells you how you're going to move,
right?
So you're going to move
three times in the game.
It tells you how you're
gonna move the first time.
It tells me how you're gonna move to the
second time and it tells you how you're
going to move the third time.
All right?
All right, so so far, none
of this seems difficult,
but actually it's a bit more difficult
than it looks. So let's have a look.
Okay.
What I want to do is I will look at
an example, and this is all fine.
I'm hoping it's going to illustrate
some subtleties about this definition.
So here's an example,
and this example,
polio one moves first and they can
choose in or out or if you're like,
that's quite an up or down to it.
That's the way you've drawn it.
So they can choose down or up.
And I'll use capital letters,U and d.
Then plant,
if shoes is APP,
then player two gets to move and play.
A two can choose left or right.
And if player one moves up,
followed by a player to choosing left,
then play a one gets to move.
In which case player one
could move up or down.
I'll use little letters this time.
Little U and D.
Okay.
All right, let's, that's
some payoffs in this game.
So the payoffs are one zero here,
zero two here,
three one here, and two, four,
yeah.
All right, so on paper, on your, it's
on the board, you first look at it.
This is a perfectly simple game.
It's just like many of the Games we've
been looking at since the mid term.
It has a tree, we could analyze
it. My back had an induction.
In a moment we will analyze it
by backward induction. All right.
But what I want to do first is I want
to say what are the strategies in this
game? All right? So let's
start with player too,
since it's easier.
Play a tos strategies.
Yeah.
Oh, wash. I'm pretty simple.
Play at two strategies.
Prior to only has one decision node,
here's player to his decision node,
right?
And the strategy has to tell a player to
what he's going to do at that decision
node. So there's only two
choices left or rights.
So player a WHO's trenches
are either left or right.
Okay. Newsies, however, already
won state subtlety here,
play a two may never
get to make this choice.
All right,
so play a two is choosing left or rights.
But player to me don't ever get to me
to make this choice. In particular,
if one shows down,
it's really irrelevant whether a player
too has chosen left or right, right?
Nevertheless,
that strategy has to specify
what play out to would do,
where he called upon to make that move.
All right,
now it's like a play on one strategies.
So what a player one strategies
in this game. What to play?
One strategist,
I didn't take hers.
Don't want to guess.
So I claim it's tempting,
it's tempting,
but it turns out to be wrong to say that
player one has three strategies here.
It's tempting to say I
either player one moves down,
in which case we're done.
Oh playing one moves up,
in which case at some later dates she may
be called upon to choose our pour down
again.
Yeah,
it's very tempting to think the player
one has just three strategies here down,
in which case we're well up
followed by either up or down,
depending on what,
a little bit,
either up or down if she's
reached to that point, right?
But actually if we followed
this definition carefully,
we noticed that player one
actually has four strategies here.
Let me see what they are and
you'll see why it's a little odd.
So here's one of the strategies
we talked about up followed by up.
And here's another one we talked
about up followed by down,
but I claim there are two others down,
followed by up and down,
followed by down,
right?
So what's a little weird about this?
What's weird is we know perfectly
well that is player one chooses down.
She's not going to get to me because the
choice, the second choice up or down.
But nevertheless,
the strategy has to tell us what she
would do at every node regardless of
whether that note actually is reached
by that strategy. Let me start again.
The strategy has to tell you what payer
one would do at that node regardless of
whether that node is actually
reached by playing that strategy.
All right. Just a little weird, right?
There's a bit of redundancy here.
It's a bit redundant.
All right, now why? Well,
we'll see why in a second. Let's
first of all, consider, uh, what,
how this game will be played according
to backward induction. All right,
so how do we play this game according
to backward induction? What do we start?
Shouldn't be a trick question,
right?
Where do we start the game according
to backward induction at the end? Okay,
so the end here is player one and
player one will choose here to go down.
It's not right because
three is bigger than two.
So if we roll back to play
a tos move play a two.
If she chooses left, she knows that she'll
be followed by playing one going down.
In which case she'll get one.
But if you choose is right,
she'll get to so play a
two we'll choose right.
All right, so play a
one. So play a one here.
If she chooses op then play a two.
We'll choose rights and
pay a one will get zero.
And if you shoes his down she'll get one.
So play on one. We'll shoes down. Alright,
so backward induction suggests that player
one will choose down and followed by
player too. If pair two didn't get to
move to choose rights for applied by one,
if you do get to move again,
choosing down again.
All right.
GNOSIS that backward induction had to
tell us what player too would have done
had she got to move
and backward induction had to consider
what player too would think that player
one would have done.
We're play or one that to get to move
again to do backward induction play,
a one has to ask herself what
player two is going to do and play.
It too has to therefore ask herself
what player one would have done,
which means play a one has to also vote
player two things by a one would have
done, which means we actually needed
to say what player one did over here.
Okay,
miss that again. So backward induction
here tells us that play one chooses down,
in which case the game is over.
But to do backward induction,
to think through backward induction,
we really needed to consider not
just what player two is going to do.
We're here to get to move,
but also what player too would
think player one would do.
We're player to to get to move on
toward ordered shoes left. All right,
so all of these redundant moves or
actually part of our backward induction,
right? We need them there so we can
think about what people are thinking.
All right,
so backward induction tells us that
the outcome of the game is down.
All right? But it tells in
terms of strategies, play out,
one chooses down and worship.
You get to move again,
which shoes down again and
play a two chooses, right?
Right
now let's analyze this game
a totally different way.
Okay,
we now know what the strategies are on
the game play or two has two strategies
left and rights and sorry,
prior to I left and rights and play
a one has four strategies up, up, up,
down, down, up and down, down. All right,
so let's write out the
Matrix for this game.
All right,
so here it is.
It must be a four by two matrix play a
two is choosing between left and rights
and play.
A one is choosing
between her four strategies up, up, up,
down, down, up and down,
down
and we can put all the payoffs in.
So up up left gets us to here,
which is too full up, up, up right,
gets us here,
which is zero to
up down left gets us here,
which is three Oh put down, right,
gets us here again,
which is zero two and down,
up or down up or gets us going right
out of the game of Middle East.
So we're going to go to one zero and in
fact that's also true for down up right.
And it's also true for down, down
left and it's also true for down down,
right.
All right,
so all of these four strategies at the
bottom started off by player one choosing
down,
in which case the game is over.
So once again in this matrix you can
kind of see the redundancy I was talking
about. All right. And this
matrix, the third row,
the down up row looks the
same as the down down row.
Everyone's happy with that.
All right.
So when we've had major
season in the past,
how have we sold the game and we've been
doing this a backward induction stuff
for a couple of weeks,
but prior to the midterm,
if effectively given you this on the
mid term, what would you have done?
You're just don't. You'd looked for Nash
Equilibrium, right? So how does this,
let's do that.
Let's look for Nash Equilibrium.
So if player two shoes is left,
then player one player, one's
best response is up, up,
and if player to chooses rice,
then play a one's best response is
either down or up or down. Down,
right?
Conversely, if player one
chooses up up, then play a tos,
best response is left.
If player one chooses up down,
then play it as best response is rights.
If player one chooses down up,
then player two doesn't care
because they're getting zero anyway.
And if player one chooses down down,
then again play a two doesn't care
because they're getting a zero anyway.
All right,
so the Nash equilibrium in this game,
how was so one of them is here.
All right,
so that's one nash equilibrium.
One of them is down, down, followed by,
right.
Okay.
[inaudible] Nash Equilibrium.
We actually found by backward induction,
right?
They,
the Nash equilibrium down down rights
corresponds to the one we found by
backward induction.
All right,
but there's another nash
equilibrium in this game.
The other now she could have
run this game. It is this one.
All right. That's also a nash
equilibrium. And what does it involve?
It involves down,
up and writes down.
Up and right. Sorry. Down, down,
up and right
down. Up and right. All
right. It's what w what?
What happened in that equilibrium player?
One went down which made everything else
kind of irrelevant player to play to
write and play a one in this,
in that plan of action was
actually going to choose up
right to it again,
play a one in fact went down player to
had they got to move would have chosen,
right? Right. And playing one.
How'd they got to move at this
second time would have chosen up.
So how can that be a nash equilibrium?
It doesn't correspond
to backward induction.
I in particular player one player,
one up here is choosing a
strategy that seems silly, right?
That's choosing up rather than down,
which gets them to rather than three
runs or how could it possibly be that
that's an equilibrium strategy.
The reason is the reason they can be
in equilibrium strategy is it doesn't
really matter what player one chooses
up here from player one's point of view
because it's never going
to be reached anyway.
As long as player two is
going to choose little rights,
one of the player two is choosing rights.
It really doesn't matter.
Master what player one decides to do
up there from play one's point of view,
it doesn't make a difference
isn't reached anyway. All right,
so we're highlighting here a
danger and the danger is this.
If you just mechanically find
the Nash Equilibria in a game,
you're going to find people choosing
actions that if they ever were called upon
to make them are silly.
Is that again,
if you're just mechanically find the Nash
equilibrium in the game just as we did
here,
you're going to select some actions in
this case and action by player one that
was she called upon and take that action
would be a silly action and the reason
it's surviving our analysis is because
in fact she isn't called upon to make it
all right.
Now to make that more concrete,
let's take this to an economic example.
This same idea,
all
right?
One or you want to imagine is a market
and in this market that is a monopolist
who controls the market
entrance?
Who is thinking of entering
into this market? All right,
so right now this market is
a monopoly in it. All right?
So in in the monopolist isn't incumbent,
that's called them ink and an
who is trying to decide whether or not
to enter the market or whether just stay
hours.
If they stay out,
then the entrance gets nothing
and incumbent continues
to get monopoly profits.
I think that this is 3 million a year,
right?
If the entrant enters their name,
common can do one of two things.
The incumbent could choose
to fight the entrance.
By which I mean charge low prices,
advertise a lot,
try and drive them out of the market.
You can pay very competitively,
in which case the entrance will actually
make losses from incumbents will drive
higher profits down to zero.
All right.
Conversely,
the incumbent could choose not to fight.
If they don't fight,
then they'll certainly share the markets
and they'll move. They'll both make,
let's say Cornell profits or
duopoly profits of a million each.
All right? So in this game, as I
say again, there's a market there.
The monopolist is in the market and the
monopolist is making 3 million a year,
which seems pretty nice for
the monopolist. Alright?
The entrance is trying to decide
whether to invade this market.
If she invented this market, if
she's fought, she's in trouble.
But if the,
if the monopolous accommodate sir,
then they just go to [inaudible] profits
and then in front does very well.
It gets $1 million in profit.
All right,
let's have a look at this game
analyzed at first of all this time.
Let's analyze it by nash equilibrium.
All right,
so I claim in this game
just pretty simple.
The entrance has two strategies.
You put it straight into the matrix.
The entrance has two strategies there
either to go in order to stay out,
and the incumbent has two strategies.
They are either to fight the
entrance or not to fight.
All right? And the payoffs
of this game are as follows.
It's been a minute in fights,
was minus one zero in a not
fights was one one and out
led to the incumbents
maintaining a monopoly profits.
Let's have a look at the Nash
equilibrium of this game. All right,
so the first thing to do is to look at
the best responses for the entrance.
So if the incumbent chooses fights,
then the entrance best
response is to stay out.
If the incumbent chooses not fights,
then the entrance best
response is to answer.
Alright, how about for the incumbent?
If the entrance chooses to come in,
then the incumbent's best response is
not to fight because one is bigger than
zero.
But if the entrance space,
it really doesn't matter what the income
does, they'll get three either way.
All right,
so the Nash Equilibria here,
I either in followed by not fighting.
You end up with a duopoly
or
I out followed by fighting.
Of course,
the fight doesn't take place out followed
by we would afford had you entered.
All right,
so these are the Nash Equilibria. Let's
analyze this game. My backward induction,
right from the incumbents point of view.
If the incumbent gets to move, then as
you're going to choose fight or not fight,
she's going to choose not fight.
So the entrance should do what,
okay,
somebody, they understood her
cause if she ends up, she gets one.
If she stays out to get zero.
So backward induction,
backward induction
just gives us this equilibrium.
All right?
Now the question is what do we think's
going on with this other equilibrium?
Let's talk it through. All
right? So here you are.
You're about to enter the market.
You leave Yale,
you set up your business and your
business is challenging some monopolist or
cause a monopolist like um, Microsoft
say, and you go out there and you put it,
you, you're, you're about to put
out your new operating system.
And you knew that your offer,
your new operating system will make
plenty of money provided Microsoft doesn't
retaliate and charged a drop its prices
by half and advertise you out of the
market. All right, so what
does Bill Gates do? Bill Gates,
the head of Microsoft, he says, wait a
second, before you graduate from Yale,
it goes up this company. Ah, let me
just tell you, I'm going to fight.
If you answer, I'm going to fight right?
And if you believe him,
if you believe that he's going to fights,
what should you do?
You're not going to bother to enter his
market or you believe that you're gonna
get fought by Bill Gates, then you,
then you believe that if you enter,
you're going to make losses.
So you choose to stay hours.
And this threat,
this threat that that Bill Gates makes
here is that it doesn't cost them
anything. Provided you go out, he
doesn't actually have to fight at all,
right?
That's why it is in fact an
equilibrium to imagine you staying out,
believing that you're going to get
fought if you enter and it is the best
response for the guy to fight,
knowing that you're going to stay out,
but this doesn't sound right.
Why this sound right?
It doesn't sound right because you
really shouldn't believe the guy who says
he's going to fight you when you know
that if you did answer facing would cost
the incumbent money. If you did
answer, if he fights you get zero.
If he doesn't fight, he
gets $1 million. All right,
so this threat that the
guy is going to fight you,
this threat is not credible,
okay?
Right?
This isn't equilibrium,
but it realize it relies on believing.
I'm believing
an incredible threat.
It's true that if you're,
if you think about entering the
markets that Microsoft is in,
you're very likely to get a
little email from bill gates.
So it won't be an email cause
that can be taken to court,
but some of the freshman and remark
and your air from Bill Gates,
it's true if you entered into the
market that the people who build airline
aircraft to in the head of Boeing might
pay you a call one day or send someone
round, right? But these threats are
not credible. France, is that right?
Then not credible threats because we know
that if you did into it isn't in their
interest to fight that making
a little noise about it,
but you notice you did into backward
induction tells us they're not going to
fight.
All right.
All right,
but now we're in slightly
in obs situation. All right.
Why are we in an odd
situation? Two things. One,
we seem to be finding that there
are Nash Equilibria in Games.
We found one here and one up here.
There are Nash Equilibria that are
not supported by backward induction.
That's the first.
That's the first reason we're,
we're a little worried here and the
second reasonable worried it's even the
economics of this doesn't
quite smell right. Right.
For example, if you in
fact did inter, sorry,
if you did in fact announce
you're going to operate a,
you're going to build a new operating
system and got a threatening phone call
from Bill Gates. The might be a reason
why you might actually believe that call.
Why might you believe that call?
Why might you believe that? Cool. Can
we get it? Can we get a mic out? Let me,
let me try it. I'll do it. I'll do it.
So why might you believe a call from Bill
Gates saying he's going to beat you up
and not be, you are, but he's
going to charge low prices.
If you produced an operating system,
he looks at the,
if you look at the future revenue streams,
like for the next 10 years
and he consistently gets
$1 million for the next 10
years,
you'll be better off if he just drove
you out of the market for the first year
and then get
$3 million for the next nine
years. How that one? Yeah. Okay.
That wasn't quite what I'm thinking.
I'll be like, okay, it's true if we,
if we cheats of base and make one of
the, okay. So what you're saying is, uh,
I could get three forever unless
there's one from it. As soon.
These are both present. This
kind of devalues a future
future cash Eddings right.
So we've done, we've done the, we've done
the future cash flow analysis of this,
right? So this isn't an
accounting mistake. All right?
Not for accounting reasons.
There's some other reason why gates,
when gates threatens you,
you might want to believe it.
I'm gonna try up here first.
You can afford to make an example of
you so know other people in vain, right?
Right. So one of the thing that's in
Bill Gates mind is he's right now,
he's thinking about competing with you,
right?
But down the road there's a lot more
of you guys coming, right? This,
whatever it is,
280 view in this room and there's another
280 and next years passed and so on.
And Bill Gates knows that each of you
might come out and threatened his monopoly
in his Microsoft monopoly and he wanted,
he might think that by setting
an example to one of you,
he might be able to keep the others out
and somewhere that kind of arguments,
the argument of making an example
of somebody is missing here missing
completely, but it's going
to be important, right?
It's got to be an important idea.
Alright,
so we're going to come back and spend
the first half of Wednesday's class
picking up that just precisely that idea.